tensions growing between the US and
Tehran after Iranian backed militants
tried to storm the American Embassy in
Baghdad the attack ending when the
militia left the scene after just two
days the Trump administration responded
by sending hundreds of troops to the
area but media coverage of what happened
is getting major backlash some outlets
slamming the president and even trying
to label the incident as Trump's
Benghazi here's a look at some of the
coverage you've got them stoking
anti-americanism potentially giving an
advantage to Iran this goes back to a
really strategic decision that the
president made we're engaged in a war of
words which is certainly not hopeful
they're tough times and one worries
whether the administration has the sort
of horsepower and brainpower to deal
with them and MSNBC's joy Reid piling on
with this tweet calling the embassy
attack Trump's Benghazi and other
outlets like the Washington Post under
fire for label labeling the Iranian
backed militants as just protesters the
New York Times is also facing similar
criticism for describing the attackers
as mourners a former Benghazi team
member is blasting them Benghazi
comparisons it's not really similar at
all it wasn't another Benghazi he's not
Trump's Benghazi and to me it wasn't
even close to Benghazi I kind of laughed
when some said oh this is Trump's
Benghazi no it's not because all again
all the non-essential personnel were
evacuated there was no ambassador there
to be killed like they'd left the
ambassador in Benghazi
Loren's there wouldn't be comparisons to
Benghazi if there wasn't a Benghazi
right there really it really is not
comparable at all and tig said it well
but tanta also says there's a difference
between a riot who he was also there and
a coordinated attack and the response
was also different there were no lives
lost the fact is that the president from
immediately in the Defense Department a
Secretary of State all stepped in and
made sure that there were people there
Marines are already there
people are being shifted and nobody died
I just think this shows you how far the
media is willing to go to give cover to
Democrats and you think when it comes to
national
security foreign policy although we may
have some differences when it comes to
attack we should be unified on it and
the fact that they are carrying the
water the democratic party is pretty
safe I mean you know probably more about
this attack than anybody here so howdy
what do you think about attempts to
compare this I mean one of the things
that happened in Benghazi was the video
maker got arrested and basically they
did a perp walk of him saying that the
video sparked the attack wouldn't out
mean when of course we know that wasn't
true there are very different situations
the compound in Baghdad is incredibly
well fortified it's it's very well
protected obviously the Benghazi outpost
was in the front lines of an ongoing
civil war an actual better comparison to
Benghazi I think it was the attack in
New Year early in the Trump
administration were for American service
members were killed in a very botched
operation I don't think the comparison
is good here some of the people we
played though in those clips weren't
talking about Benghazi they were talking
about what President Trump's strategy is
VESA the Iran and whether he has won
quite frankly and I think my concerns
here aren't about some Benghazi
comparison it's about the fact that much
of what the Trump administration has
done has emboldened the hardliners in
Iran the IRGC today feels like they can
encourage their militias in places like
Iraq and Syria to do this and we have to
figure out how we're going to respond
you know the Israelis have taken a lot
of kinetic action against Shiite
militias backed by Iran in places like
Iraq and Syria but they do it much more
quietly because they're trying to send a
message but not provoke some of the
outrage that you've seen on the ground
which unfortunately can't put our people
in harm's way thankfully we've evacuated
the embassy but a result of that is that
we don't have people on the ground doing
American diplomacy as many have Marines
that are there to help protect that
right that Iran has been able to train
up all of these other militias is
because they got a lot of money during
the Obama administration now it's full
of se POA but what difference at this
point does it make call back that's all
that the thing is that I want to shame
the media on this because you know those
headlines from the outlets like the
Washington Post New York Times they have
to differentiate between there are
protests in Iraq since
October real protests and I this is what
you see on social media you see people
you know on Twitter saying I'm one of
the real protests I've been protesting
this government because they are very
angry in Iraq about they want reforms
yes
and so Iranians have come in and
piggybacked on those protests in the
media needs to differentiate and they're
not doing their job in saying that
they're very demonstration their
administration has done that we also
have some sound here from President
Trump like Emily I looked up and I was
like I'm gonna remember your name cuz
you know I don't even know a day of the
week it is actually been working this
during the holidays and you're like me
you're like is it Friday is it Monday I
have really no idea Emily take a listen
to President Trump who he obviously
knows what day it is as you know this
will not be a Benghazi but Ghazi should
never have happened
this will never ever be a Benghazi look
there it's not a comparable comparison
for on any level we have made drastic
efforts not to provoke iranian-backed
militias as we've been fighting Isis
this entire time and the bottom line is
that their continued aggression against
spaces could not be tolerated so I agree
with you that there's there's a bit of
nebulous honest in strategy in the past
couple years but the bottom line is
we've taken that hardline stance with a
very articulable position that will
serve us well in the long term and I
think that you know the Iraqi government
obviously they're in a difficult
position but regardless they need to
take a stance they need to protect our
embassy and you know took the to your
point about the media you know their
headline today not to jump issues but
about the the Weig or murder right now
in China they said as it detains parents
China Wiens children from Islam so we
are no stranger they are no stranger to
the fact that all of their headlines are
absolutely ludicrous in these times of
what we deserve would be political
specificity and final point my my friend
actually headed out to Baghdad today on
behalf of the US government he said as
he was checking in he flew commercial
and the woman who checked him in at the
early
counter was like Baghdad like are you
aware of what's going on right now and
he goes more than the average bear yeah
pretty well aware the New York Times
also referred to these terrorists
protesters whatever you want to call
them as mourners mourning the fact that
they got attacked yes blob was attacked
your morning that I mean yes they were
the sympathy for them but I mean which a
Tom's point I think it was a really
smart point that the people on the
ground who are protesting who are
outside our embassy are a bunch of
different people some are mourners some
are protesters but the guys being killed
right yeah there you know yes there are
they're bad guys the Iraqis as Emily
said are in a tough position because
they want this place to be safe they
want our embassy to be safe they also
see these airstrikes at some level as an
imposition on their sovereignty and so
they're trying to play this game where
they're trying not to allow you know
people to come onto their airspace and
to do these things but they also don't
like these iranian-backed militias
they're trying to play this middle space
here and that's really hard for the
Iraqis a government we want to be strong
going forward I just think that
comparisons to Benghazi that early did
the the types of comparisons that we saw
that would like jump the gun makes me
think that they never really understood
what happened in Benghazi in the first
place there's a great movie about that
called 13 hours catch it over the
weekend because it's only Thursday